ronny was on the wrap-up show yesterday
he had a lot to say he's weird Ronnie's
like a paranoid guy and always thinks
people are out to get him and then his
focus was Gary fluff a food hi well
that's interesting because Gary's such a
an apple I don't know but Ronnie seems
to feel Gary has it in for him but I've
seen Ronnie like this before where he
must reads people yeah but Gary you know
I gotta ask you a question because you
know it's really bugging my ass lately
like you really got a [ __ ] hard-on for
me lately and I don't know what it is I
don't have a heart you got a real like I
don't know every time my anything with
me comes up you're the first one to
stick me in the [ __ ] back right I
don't have a dagger for you Ronnie no
lately dude you do you were on fire on
the wrap-up tree you made absolutely
zero sense listen to it okay we said
you're not alright that's I had my
opinion but you had to back it up I this
is the way I feel about Gary lately
sound I know the guys right 25 years
when did you start with dude it's every
listen back to your last five
appearances with me and every word is
dude this is bother you I'm just saying
what happened to you dude you're like
all playboy yeah dude putting people
down
I have dude dude you don't know my name
what's this dude I don't call you dude
okay I never call you dude okay honey
yeah you don't know who I am yeah I know
you like do I know who you are
listen dude all right that's a put tie
do you want me to leave that's a put
leave not internally I'm trying I'm
asking you what's that half dude I have
an opinion we care about Gary okay it's
a dumb opinion you said it's not dumb
sure it is you said Gary you put me down
oh that's where Gary goes you know all
right tell me when and you go I don't
know how do you how do you look just the
way he talks about me okay give me an
example why she can't he said okay
perfect example the hallway talking to
somebody good okay
yeah he'll walk over like I'm not even
there right like I'm a piece of [ __ ] in
the script right okay this is an example
and walk into the conversation take over
the whole conference
station and make like I'm not even there
Ronnie okay that's not right don't take
it personally
that's my opinion either Ronnie's
paranoid I know dude he miss reads
people he died I miss to read everybody
everybody write my percentages are
better whatever whatever dude yeah you
feel to me dude dude yeah everything's
now no you're not yeah I am
you don't even know you're doing I know
I'm doing it now you don't you say dude
every other word okay I listen to you
whatever he was on a mad tear yesterday
because I heard him say when he was
saying about the Twitter thing and then
the guy who invented when I'm gonna
approach the guy yeah the guy who
invented Twitter is coming on and Gary
was speculating that Ronnie could
potentially go up to the Twitter guest
and say hey I want to be verified ronnie
was saying hey when do I ever bother a
guest with my needs never I know that's
not right uh-huh so he got upset about
it my observation my opinion and Gary
acts different towards me lately that's
all when did this start about a year ago
a year yeah I'm not mad at Gary I'm hurt
by the way you talk the only thing I
could tell you ronnie is and and I would
be I would tell you in a second if I had
a beef with you I take shots at you on
the wrap-up show joking around the way
we each others like joking around you
freak there's a different I don't know I
just wanted isn't it I know I like
Ronnie I've always like right I've
always got along well with him and I I
don't I don't know what to say
I should verified your verb but how are
you while he's here he could send an
email and someone could be verified
within 30 seconds Ronnie good dude dude
yeah please